bonsoir et soeur vit son merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france ces
chiffres évidemment très encourageant de
la part de la direction de la santé 1 ce
soir il n'y a pas de reprise visible de
l'épidémie qu'est ce qu'on peut en
conclure à bien ces chiffres sont donc
les chiffres que vous venez présenter
sont des indicateurs tardif l'indicateur
de admission en réanimation et
l'indicateur de décès sont très tardif
par rapport au temps de l'infection donc
bien sûr ils sont encourageants mais il
faut regarder plutôt les indicateurs
précoces c'est à dire le nombre de
nouveaux cas de kobe 19 qui sont
déclarés est bon ils diminuent également
mais probablement à si vite que ce que
l'on pourrait espérer
et il faut également regarder le nombre
de nouveaux foyers ce qu'on appelle les
clusters ces nouveaux foyers il y en a
il y en a beaucoup
enfin ya là beaucoup il y en a il y en a
c'est d'à côté il ya une c'est une bonne
nouvelle dans la mesure où on sait les
repérer on sait les détecter et on
arrive la plupart du temps à les
contrôler dira les circonscrire à éviter
que à partir de ces foyers se
développent de petites et épidémies
local ou régional mais il existe
toujours ce qui signifie que le virus
continue de circuler dans la population
française dans toutes les régions de la
france et que il n'est pas encore
question de considérer que l'épidémie
est terminée
l'épidémie est enfoui en voie
d'achèvement
mais elle n'est pas terminée donc il
faut encore prescrire les mesures
barrières un respect très strict de ces
mesures
même s'il en coûte un peu à eux mêmes
beaucoup à certains de nos compatriotes
qui aimerait reprendre la vie d'avant
alors effectivement on note ces foyers
notamment en loire atlantique dans une
école dans deux foyers leur handicap et
l'autre de mineurs à arles également
comment
vous les expliquez vous ces foyers
docteur mais on les explique par le fait
donc c'est ça traduit la circulation du
virus qui il faut se rappeler que la
particularité de cette maladie virale
c'est qu'il ya à grand nombre de formes
asymptomatiques ou très peu
symptomatiques donc des formes qui passe
inaperçu ce sont ces personnes qui tout
en gardant une vie sociale à peu près
normale c'est-à-dire en sorte en ayant
des contacts et bien mon propager le
virus
et ça c'est très difficile à détecter
alors que dans d'autres maladies on
aurait pu les détecter parce que quand
les gens étaient malades donc ils ne
sortaient pas ils étaient bloqués chez
eux
cette circulation elle se manifeste de
temps en temps justement par le foyer et
dans ses foyers il faut qu'ils aient
bien sûr des conditions propices pour la
propagation qui est des gens qu'ils
soient qui vivent là vu que dans le cas
des abattoirs par exemple il y avait des
conditions qui étaient tout à fait
favorables à la dissémination du virus
parce que les gens travaillaient dans
des conditions très de promiscuité et de
température qui est favoriser la
dissémination du virus les domaines les
écoles les collectivités quelles
qu'elles soient sont des endroits qui
sont des révélateurs de la circulation
du virus
donc ce n'est pas étonnant de voir que
ce sont dans ces endroits que survienne
la plupart des foyers
la difficulté c'est effectivement de les
circonscrire donc de les détecter le
plus tôt possible grâce à l'utilisation
des tests maintenant on a suffisamment
de tests pour le faire est de repérer
par le traçage toutes les personnes qui
ont pu être en contact avec les cas de
façon à les tester à leur tour et elle
est isolée si c'est nécessaire vous
l'avais dit il ya des foyers il ya des
nouveaux cas plus que l'on espérait
mais les chiffres d'admissions à
l'hôpital semble marquer le pas en être
en baisse ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que finalement le virus est moins
virulent qu'avant où on ne peut pas
tirer cette conclusion
non le virus est toujours aussi virulent
je pense qu'il n'a pas évolué depuis
plusieurs semaines mais les diminutions
d'entrée comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure en bonne service à l'hôpital et
dans le service de réanimation
traduisent des infections qui ont eu
lieu il ya deux trois semaines
la diminution du taux de mortalité
traduire des infections qui sont
survenus il ya trois semaines un mois ou
peut-être plus d'un mois donc
mais sur ce sont des indicateurs très
encourageant mais ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est agir sur les nouvelles
infections
il faut diminuer les nouvelles
infections il faut puisqu'il faut faire
en sorte que le virus cessent de
circuler
alors on était d un peu en cela par par
l'arrivée des beaux jours on va arriver
donc la saison d'été où la chaleur ne
peut aider à lutter contre la
transmission
bien sûr nos mesures barrières elles
sont toujours très très efficace mais si
le climat peut nous aider à passer ce
sera extrêmement appréciable dit dans la
mesure où ça permettra de favoriser
l'arrêt définitif de la circulation du
virus qu'il faut aller mettre cet arrêt
définitif
vous répondez presque à ma question
parce que j'allais vous demander cette
baisse des chiffres selon vous est ce
qu'elle est due justement au respect des
gestes barrières parce qu'on a vu quand
même hein voilà tous devant nos écrans
de télévision ici même qu'il ya eu des
rassemblements ici ou là des matchs
sauvage des manifestations donc est ce
qu'elle est due au respect des gestes
barrières ou est ce qu'elle est due à la
disparition tout simplement d'épidémie
comme le prédisait didier rahout une
épidémie saisonnière qui est en train de
partir comme elle est venue l est du
bien sûr aux deux facteurs mais
actuellement 20 depuis quelques semaines
depuis surtout le la date du 11 mai on
constate qu'il ya eu le
le progressive des mesures de
confinement ce qui fait que un certain
nombre de personnes ont considéré que
c'était fini les mesures de
distanciation le port du masque on a un
petit peu oublié il ya les grands
rassemblements auxquels vous auquel vous
faites allusion qui sont catastrophiques
sur le plan épidémiologique parce que là
ce sont des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui se rassemblent alors que
c'est interdit et qui échange si l on si
elles sont porteuses du virus qui
échangent des virus parce qu'on ne peut
pas faire autrement dans ce type de
rassemblement où l'on crie où on
vaporise des airs au sol avec à partir
de sa bouche il ne peut pas en être
autrement qu'il y aura des risques de
contamination dans ces rassemblements et
que par ailleurs et bien on interdit les
relais les rassemblements sportifs ou
culturels
c'est un petit peu incohérent 1 ce qui
se passe mais il est probable que cesser
ce relâchement qui agit probablement
pour dans le sens que la diminution la
fin de l'épidémie n'est peut-être pas
aussi rapides qu'elles le devraient
alors que le climat agit lui dans le bon
sens le climat favorise l'arrêt de
l'épidémie et le professeur out sur ce
plan là du moins était tout à fait dans
le vrai puisque cette affection encore
un virus et une infection qui sera
saisonnière même si au début c'était une
pandémie elle s'est répandue dans le
monde un peu indépendamment des saisons
dans lequel se trouvaient les différents
pays du monde
buisson d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous